well it's a new year are you afraid that
your hindquarters could be attacked at
any time by a ravenous wild animal
jumping out of your toilet people
probably say you're nuts you're not nuts
these are nuts I'll tell you why every
Christmas the same thing happens you
give a kid a puppy they love it then
three weeks later your kids playing the
newest murder game on that play pad no
one gives a crap about the puppy anymore
so you do what everyone does you flush
that puppy down the koi oak oh oh these
are the facts he's not lying look at his
stats don't worry none of the puppies
died they just live in the sewers where
they eat all the rodents they can get
into a double triple quadruple in size
getting bigger and angrier by the minute
these monsters are the deeper call
toilet wolf wolves
we got enough take a look at this
typical toilet wolf encounter okay honey
I'm going into the bathroom now to take
a normal poop I wonder what he means by
that
[Music]
what the wolves are real just ask plunge
or the God of plumbing
I am plunge or and toilet wolves are
real and just listen to these more stats
hey can I tell you something there's a
[ __ ] ton of mustard packets in my upper
right rider I noticed that it's not
right
figured you really look Musti I just
distracted by these I how did these end
up in here every time you buy a hot dog
you get like five mustard packet you
know next time you get a hot dog get one
mustard pack yo the next time you get a
hot dog don't buy any mustard packets
just use some of the ones they already
have any thoughts I I'm not buying them
other than lack its how do you avoid
death by toilet Wolf's by hiring smithy
and schminke
toilet wolf removal service first our
toilet will remove the specialists will
come to your home then they will put
blindfolds and noise-canceling
headphones on you so you won't be scared
then they will remove all your toilet
wolves while you relax in no time your
home will be toll free oh no not yet the
Wolves will be roaming in the wilderness
[Music]
just ask you question why would we see
the crew take this stuff in the
commercial gives you a toast well edit
this part out no puppies or wolves were
harmed during the making of this
commercial yeah but that husband and
wife they're gone
call now
[Applause]
not a new location in Glendale
California just off-brand Boulevard
between the karate studio on the nail
place
[Applause]
I've worried about those guys yeah I
think finally they got a product
American right right oh I meant finally
someone's addressing the toilet problem
hey thanks for watching be sure to click
subscribe to see even more great Conan
clips you may now return to your pirated
movies and creepy Japanese pornography